christian winkler
[Applaus]
[Musik]
christa wäre ich finde es geil
sondierung endloser wäre jetzt mal ganz
ehrlich jehring was kann man da ran denn
geil finden bitte also diese
sondierungsgespräche sind das geilste
ich das allergrößte
was mir jemals passiert ist das geht
fast schon in dem bereich supergeil
das auch niemals aufhört wird ja auch
nicht ich bin so ein fan von diesen
täglichen sinnlosen interviews was man
da alles erfährt wussten sie zum
beispiel was die rot in ihrer jutetasche
hat weiß nicht was sie in der nacht
brauchen
ich schminke mich auch nachts ständig
atemlose spannung was soll tracy claudia
als nächstes raus ein labello einer also
trotz fahne es gibt so viele
möglichkeiten klein aber dass allah
aller geilste ist ja wenn die einfach
immer weiter sortieren dann gibt es nie
eine regierung und vier bürger können
die 45 milliarden behalten
die jamaika verlusten will wir sind alle
reich oder affen tippen geil
ich glaube jährigen da machen sie jetzt
aber ein denkfehler
ich habe den porsche schon bestellt und
woher weiß ich ja woher weiß sie dass
jamal k garantiert nie kommen wird weil
ich den brand genau zuhöre achten sich
immer auf die subtilen zwischentöne
jetzt diese sehr schwierige operation zu
versuchen einem guten ende zu führen
ob das gelingt geht nicht aus dass
gelegen
wie geil ist das denn bitte bei dem
dobrindt klar hat sich im laufe der
verhandlung so viel fett zu viel gift
aufgestaut den müssen wir wahrscheinlich
bald in der asse endlagern ja es ist
alles nur noch geil
die aber deutschland braucht doch
irgendwann der regierung
achja kurzer nachfrage weiter seitz wozu
denn es läuft doch unser
wirtschaftswachstum ist im dritten
quartal so stark gestiegen wie seit
sechs jahren nicht mehr
wir dürfen diesen aufschwung jetzt nicht
durch unnötige regierungsbildung
gefährden
ich sage lasst uns von dir bis in alle
ewigkeit mein vorschlag wie sperren die
tür von dieser hütte wurden ja
verhandeln sperren wir von außen zu und
schmeißen den schlüssel weg die kommt
noch nie wieder raus ja dann würden wir
dem altmaier abo zu futter hoch auf den
balkon das reicht auch yao darunter geht
weiter mehrere geht mehr versionierung
geweniger regierung deutschland wird zur
demokratie ich habe so das gefühl
[Applaus]